we're talking seven feet and that is
going to be the good news is it's money
in the bank as far as the reservoirs but
it is a tough time to get through all
that we're going to get to your local
forecast coming up in the next 30
seconds Al Roker is back in Action so
far so good the Today's Show weatherman
made his big return Friday following his
two-month absence due to health issues
and it was emotional for everyone Al
Roker is back
[Applause]
to say we have missed you well it
doesn't even begin to describe it
there's nothing without you here I have
missed you guys so very much you are my
second family and it's just great to be
back and wearing pants
you have to do the weather yes that's
right
oh look what are all these lights but
come on this is Al of course he had no
problem doing what he does best all
right let's take a look unfortunately
our friends out west the world has there
has been socked and Soggy so we got
another store coming in late Friday
Saturday downpours across Northern
California heaviest snow in the Cascades
knocking better than ever Al is the
lifeblood of the show he's the heartbeat
he's ours we I mean we
can work without Al in November Al was
hospitalized due to blood clots in his
lungs and leg which caused him to step
away from work and a lot of you have
been uh wondering about our buddy Al
wilker well this morning we can tell you
that he is doing well at the time Al
wrote on Instagram that he was fortunate
to be getting terrific Medical Care and
on the way to recovery but shortly after
returning home he was hospitalized again
well I was in the hospital for four
weeks so you know it it's just a certain
amount of weakness that I'm doing
physical therapy every day uh
occupational therapy I've got to just
get my strength back despite Al's
absence during the holidays his
colleagues made sure to include him in
all their festivities like their video
holiday card
[Music]
yeah and they even surprised him with
some holiday cheer at home
[Music]
[Applause]
at the end of the day what's important
is you go home to the people you love
and and you know you you work with the
people that you respect and and that's
all that matters and now according to
Al's trusted co-anchors he's back and
stronger than ever how is this feature
going to look is he going to be there
every day at the show or do you think I
think so as far as we know I think
they'll have to hold them back I mean I
think you know all of us around him are
saying you're take it easy buddy but
it's Al Roker but yeah he's the
Energizer Bunny and I you know I hope he
takes as much time as he wants to but I
think he's really excited to come back
to work and we're excited to have him
foreign